Speaker 1: I want to do another segment on the
recent leak of tax information about American
billionaires that was leaked by ProPublica
recently. Because I am seeing a ton of people
seemingly misunderstanding the significance of the
story. ProPublica leaked the taxes of some of the
wealthiest people in the United States, and they
came up with something they are calling the true
tax rate. Now, the true tax rate is an interesting
metric, but it's important to understand
that the true tax rate is not something that
is related to tax law. The true tax rate, as
called by ProPublica, relates to how much did you
pay in taxes relative to how much your net worth
went up. And that includes something we call
unrealized gains in the United States. This may
not be something anybody cares about, but I think
this is a really important detail to understand.
The true tax rate that ProPublica came up with is
based on an idea that is not how we tax people in
the United States. In the U.S., we tax people from
an income and capital gains standpoint, unrealized
gains in just about every situation. If your stock
portfolio doubles, but you don't sell any stock,
you don't pay taxes on those gains because
you've not realized those gains. Now, what
is an exception to that, and it's an important
exception, is property taxes on real estate,
in property taxes. There's something called the
assessed value of your property. So if you own a
property and you buy it and it's assessed by your
city as being worth four hundred thousand dollars,
you pay a yearly property tax on four hundred
thousand dollars of value. Now, if in the next
year the value of the property goes up to 500000
and the city comes by and reassesses your property
at five hundred thousand dollars, even though
you didn't sell the property, in a sense, you
didn't realize the gains, you immediately pay more
taxes. That is an exception in the United States.
But generally speaking, in the U.S., we do not
pay taxes on unrealized gains. We don't have
that for stocks. We don't have that for bonds.
If people want that, you have to lobby for it.
So I think that the ProPublica article was
very interesting, not because Warren Buffett
is doing anything wrong or illegal by not paying
taxes on unrealized stock market gains. That's
not Warren Buffett is doing. It's not even
really a loophole. It's the way the system
is designed. It's not even you're not really
circumventing the letter nor the spirit of the law
in the United States as if we didn't know it. We
have a system that favors people who earn money
from assets rather than who earn money from labor.
When you go out and work and you get paid a salary
or an hourly wage, you are realizing those gains
immediately. As far as the tax code is concerned,
you took your labor, you went to work for a week,
you sold your labor and you got money. You realize
the gains on the sale of your labor and now you
immediately pay taxes. We. All that income taxes,
on the contrary, when I when my Tesla stock right.
Doubled and tripled and quadrupled and quintupled,
right. It went crazy. I didn't pay any taxes
on it until I panic sold half of it stupidly
because I thought Elon Musk was going to
be absolutely destroyed for smoking pot
with Joe Rogan and saying, I might take
the company private or whatever it was.
So I panicked, sold half of my stock. I realized
the gains and then I paid taxes on it. That's the
way things work. So the important takeaway for me
from the ProPublica story is if you want to change
that, you have to change the reality of how the
tax system works. And there's a misunderstanding
about it in the sense that the true tax rate, as
described by ProPublica, it's not a real thing
and none of the billionaires are breaking the
law. We just have a system where you pay taxes,
unrealized gains and wages. Now, there's also a
different take on the story. That is pretty funny.
I came across this yesterday when researching my
segment on the online left. I mentioned that The
Hill's show or Channel Rising has new hosts.
I found out about this a couple of days ago.
The one clip I saw, I'm not even going to play it
because I don't want to give it any attention. The
one clip I saw, the two new hosts who I guess it's
the idea that you've got a left and a right wing
host now still on the Hill. They were agreeing.
The issue with the ProPublica story is that the
tax information leaked at all. Guys, that is not
it. You know, we can talk about these are private
citizens. There's a discussion to have about
obtaining and leaking people's taxes. But the
big hot take on this story from hosts supposedly
on the left and right is how did we even learn
about this stuff? And that's really wrong. They
sound like the people who, after Edward Snowden,
exposed all of these bulk surveillance techniques
that are extremely oppressive in terms of the
violation of privacy and really do very little to
prevent terrorism. There were a couple of people
after that who were saying, I can't believe that
this was made public and that that we know about
it. We need to focus on how it was made public.
Give me a break, guys. That is not the story here,
but there is a real story here and it's an
interesting one. And it is, again, just the
reminder that in the U.S. we have a system
that heavily favors making money from assets
rather than making money from working. Let me know
your thoughts. You can find me on Twitter at David
Pakman. I would really love it if you grabbed
yourself a membership on my website at Join Pakman
Dotcom, the number one way to support our show, we
do an extra show every single day. I'm joined by
producer Pat Daly and we do an extra show for our
members. And it's an award winning show. It really
is, although we've given out all of the awards
and you can sign up at Join Pakman dot com coupon
code available better 21. Feel free to pay full
price, but feel free to take the discount as well.